seen an iPad kit I'm like wow what job
is he gonna have he knows more about
scrolling to the next video than like
anything that will help get a job
[Music]
[Applause]
high schoolers are kids
three two one
I feel like to say high schoolers in
general are kids is almost like
defeating the people who are in the
minority like for people like me who
have grown up more um just mature for my
age and I guess fitting more an adult
mindset I feel like I can't say for
myself that I'm a kid because I
definitely make adult decisions time and
time again I mean there are people who
still have the mindset of kids but I
can't say high schoolers in general are
kids I feel like with
high school it's such a broad statement
to say high schoolers because there's a
giant difference between a freshman and
a senior like it is that's why like when
they try to date each other it's like
why is that 18 year old trying to date
the 14 year old like it just doesn't
make sense I feel like it would be naive
to ignore the fact that like especially
anyone who's a senior they're about to
be a legal adult I think kids need
mentoring that's how I see it I mean
adults too need mentoring but I think
kids need that extra help and that extra
push I've seen many kids who have been
forced to be older or act older as they
are to mature faster that's why I went
for agree
well I agree I feel like there's just so
many decisions especially in high school
that we have to make that are not like
kid-like and they expect us to act a
certain way and also like the fact that
we're even able to drive how should we
still be considered a kid do you mind if
I move yeah
um I moved because I feel like
especially at that 16 to 18 age you're
constantly planning for your future
where it's actually difficult to live in
your childhood it's just kind of you're
unable to live as a child so it's like
how can you consider yourself when when
you're constantly planning for your
adult life and future when I was a
freshman all
told me that I needed to prepare for my
future and I feel like especially coming
after online school and quarantine I'm
still living in that middle schooler
mindset I'm still basically like a kid
living and preparing for my future which
I'm clearly not ready for
I feel like kid is kind of a weird word
so like it's just kid and adult and I
feel like in high school you kind of
want I kind of want to be thought of as
a kid because it's kind of like oh he's
a kid right it's like a like an excuse
almost like you're allowed to mess up I
I really can't like look at my classes
full of 18 year olds and say these are
these are adults like
I feel like now it's later and later
we're turning into adults I don't feel
like we turn in I mean of course there's
people that have to pay bills at 16 but
say a high schooler is an adult I feel
like I like to know that I can grow so
much more from that like oh I did that
when I was a kid not you know as an
adult
today's high schoolers have it harder
than previous generations
three two one go
hmm
I feel like now our generation we have
more resources
for help that we need you know and way
back then like mental health that was
like they would put you straight to Camp
or like some conversion stuff like that
but I feel like now there's just more
resources we have the internet we have
the media like would you have wanted to
send a pigeon to your friend instead of
texting your friend like you know stuff
like that like would you want to have
you know we just have it easier now I
feel like it's an in-between thing
because I feel like social situations
now are much better but back then they
were much worse I feel like there was
racism teachers could beat their own
kids and I feel like now there's so much
things that we cannot do and I feel like
it's for the better can I move
when I think about this question I kind
of like went to bullying and how much
easier it is to get bullied nowadays
especially on social media because it's
so easy to hide behind a screen people
say worse things and I think that mental
health maybe it was just as bad back in
the day but because of social media it's
become more prominent and we see it
everywhere
um another thing that I also thought
about was you guys say that we have more
resources but don't you while you don't
have to agree but I feel that the
resources have kind of made us a little
less smart because we're able to look up
that like the answers to our test or
like I don't know everything's just so
much more accessible that I'm not really
learning as much as like my mom and dad
did so I kind of like sad that all our
resources are so much more accessible
yeah we like I know some of them you
know people like they're like is it hot
outside and then they'll go to their
phone and check the weather like just go
outside you know I feel like school
right now is so easy fraud generation
like it is so incredibly easy like
especially now that I'm in senior year I
mean I'm not taking incredibly hard
classes but like they don't even give
you homework because they know you won't
do it like it's like they would rather
have you pass than like teach you
something and like the amount of kids
that held back is like nothing like it's
just oh keep going ahead go ahead go
ahead and so like
see my classrooms from like older
Generations it seems like oh they're
like learning there's more respect to
the teachers now like there's like such
little discipline that every class is
just like a muck I feel like just
because things are easier does not mean
it's better my friend goes to college in
San Diego and there's literally a group
chat for people in a nursing major just
to cheat on the work and if we're having
nurses that don't even know how to like
give you medicine stuff like that it's
scary I did want to hit on how the
pandemic impacted you guys yeah I think
it did impact Our Generation I know
personally I was I was always so great
at talking growing up and then going
into coronavirus not really like talking
to my friends a bunch and like being
kind of like antisocial into myself
coming out and having to talk to adults
was like terrifying I didn't want to do
it at all I didn't I couldn't even talk
to like my peers when I went back to
school I felt like I was still in eighth
grade in Middle School so it was very
hard for me to adjust and this was
definitely like the biggest
change like that affected Our Generation
if you think about it you know we didn't
deal with the Bubonic plague or a big
you know stuff like that like we this
was the biggest impact and I remember
going back to school I was so anxious
like I would
take half a Xanax you know almost every
morning because it was so bad there was
this day where we can finally take off
our mask it was so weird saying everyone
but I never knew what to do with my face
it was just crazy I feel ready to
explore my sexuality
three two one go
I knew I was gay at a very young age
um so I've kind of always been ready or
kind of always known like I was over
here like six years old like looking at
a TV screen and there's like a boy and I
was like he's cute like I was like yeah
I already knew so like I feel like it
just depends what you determine what
exploring your sexuality is because at
least in my book I feel like I've
already labeled it and I'm already
confident and happy with who I am now
it's very normal to explore yourself and
I think even just like having sex it's
very very naive for any adult or anyone
to ignore the fact that like people are
gonna do that like it's it's where
people around you are gonna do that are
gonna talk about it or you're gonna see
it on TV and with the internet like we
have access to everything these days no
one is judged like for waiting or
wanting to try stuff as long as
everyone's being safe as long as it's
consensual as long as you're okay
there's nothing wrong with it I also
grew up in a very private Christian
School it was very like it was like a
bubble you know and you know we didn't
talk about all that stuff but now I
attend a high school where we actually
have Wellness classes also social media
helps those random accounts on my for
you page they're like
how to kiss a boy or something like that
I don't even know what is it wikiHow
wikiHow sure like there's just so many
horses you know that's why you got to
seek them out and find a support system
it's kind of like for our whole
generation happening earlier and earlier
like where we get introduced to it with
like the internet and stuff I kind of
like it to be delayed I kind of like to
be a kid for as long as I can but do you
feel like people don't take you
seriously if you continue to
you know act younger and like want to be
younger in in the sense of like this
question like sexuality like I I feel
like I'd rather because right now it's
like most of the pressure is just like
oh I feel like I'm so behind because I
haven't done this this and this yet when
it should be so normal it's important
that we do educate ourselves on these
topics because once we're older if we
aren't that could take a turn for the
worse I feel like approaching it
naturally or in a professional way like
in terms of like school if they're
providing like Health classes I think
that's just the best way to go about it
and I completely agree with you like I
was also exposed to nasty on the
internet and like no one wants to go
through that I don't think that the
school should do it because I think it's
really weird you know I I can never stop
laughing personally like when I'm in a
sixth grader and they say the word
scrotum how are you not supposed to like
laugh I don't know I think I think it's
more of a personal Endeavor but I guess
not not everyone's as smart as me but I
feel like personally I just like to find
that out on my own and maybe be
encouraged by the school but I don't
like the classroom let's learn about sex
of all sitting together as a bunch of
teenagers like that sounds that's awful
that's like the worst thing ever I feel
safe at school
three two one go
my campus security are amazing
um they have a personal relationship
with all the students I've had bomb
threats at my school I've had like
shootings literally walking distance
down the street where the school had to
go on lockdown it's unfortunate but also
like it just makes me really aware like
for every classroom I have what's my
hide plan who are my people I don't feel
comfortable putting my phone in the
phone chart because if something happens
I want to text my family and that's why
kovid like lifted a lot of weight off my
shoulders because I didn't have to worry
about that all the time
um also like a lot of people at my
school who have mental health struggles
um I'm always afraid that like someone
won't be properly treated for that and
then they'll just snap one day you know
my school has had multiple sexual
assault scandals
um like my history teacher right now my
world history teacher if it weren't for
the current sub it would be with
basically a pedophile so it's it's scary
and when she mentioned like the bomb I
think I remember last year someone
created an account with our school name
and it was like shooting or something on
this day and our school ended up
canceling school for that day and it was
horrible I feel so fortunate to have
grown up in a really privileged area
where there's not a lot of violence
however I feel like I would be ignorant
to say that a school shooting would
never happen because all it takes is one
kid out of the 2500 students that I have
to take a gun to school and shoot people
and I feel like there's so many
different openings on my campus where
that could happen we have Gates but it
honestly looks like a prison okay yeah I
won't lie
um we have security guards they're not
armed which was a conversation that came
up should our security guards be armed
and another conversation came up should
our teachers be on you know there's just
topics like that I remember when this
was actually recently
um one of the old students at the
college
threatened to shoot up the whole school
and so even we had to go remote so it's
just like never feel safe my social
media presence is important to me
three two one go
foreign
you know but like I'm not like
constantly posting and if you do that's
perfectly fine like that's a lot of
people's outlets and especially
creativity I don't own a single social
media and like like not as like a flex
I'm just saying like I I hate the the
presence of an app in my mind like oh
you should do this like it's a it's an
app on my phone like I don't want to
give it any part of my life so I'd just
rather not have it I think sometimes
with social media nowadays it also can
fall into career which is really weird
but that's like what I do it's like oh I
can't post that picture of me like
flipping off the camera with my friends
because like a college or a future boss
because your digital footprint is so
real but I also like I love having
social media like I've had it for years
I've always like tried to ground myself
and realize that it's just for fun it's
not that serious there are some people
who I know who have like shown or done
some really crazy stuff and it's spread
everywhere like there's some things I do
not need to to know and people just tell
me like on Instagram there's like close
friends and there's like normal story
and I post on close friends so much more
than I do on my normal store or like a
Spam account yeah yeah I posted my spam
account like way more a couple years ago
I would have been right there like on
the strongly agree you know like because
when I moved to the new school a lot of
people were like oh how many followers
do you have if you had over a thousand
it's like yo you got clout like you
you're good digital footprint that is no
joke like everything you post will come
back at you I'm so glad Instagram took
off that feature where you could see
what other people liked do you all
remember that that was ridiculous that's
why I'm very aware of what I post I make
sure this is what I want everyone to see
and you know when you're yes I'm so
sorry when you're a kid like you want
social media like when you first find
out about it like when I was nine years
old I was like begging my mom to let me
have Instagram and now like I'm even
embarrassed of like the little like
selfies I would post because like
they're so stupid so like looking back
I'm like oh yeah I would totally never
let like my seven-year-old on social
media like you know things like that
um but I actually did have social media
very young yeah me too um I got Twitter
when I was six my my mom made it and
managed it but I would still like I
would tweet about like my little
kindergarten like crutches and you like
having your mom like to like
um guide like the account I feel like I
didn't have that unfortunately so um I
feel like it just depends like your
digital print could be much more harmful
like when you don't have parents that
know how to handle social media or know
how to prevent it because my parents
they've never used social media they
don't have a single account so growing
up like begging I don't think they knew
the harmfulness of it and I don't blame
them for that at all but I feel like
that's what led to me being exposed to a
lot of stuff so I feel like definitely
with the new generation and if I don't
know if I'll have kids but if I do
they're not on social media at least for
me when those iPad kits I mean those
kids who use iPads there's an iPad
addicting it's so addicting and you need
parental controls because social media
is crazy like or having your parents run
the account regardless is just so that's
so important or even having influencers
like Andrew Tate who are like
influencing these like right little like
little boys to think that that mentality
is like normal yeah I feel like social
media has drastically altered my
personality especially during covet and
I feel like if it could change me that
much just imagine a six-year-old having
access to a phone for their basically
entire childhood but like honestly I got
so sensitive to being on in front of
camera that I feel like I kind of forgot
about digital footprint and stuff like
that I have hope
sure
three two one go
I don't know man seeing an iPad kid I'm
like wow like obviously gonna have you
know I mean he knows more about like
scrolling to the next video than like
anything that like will help get a job I
don't know I don't I don't feel like I
very much hope for our in the next
Generations as like I feel we keep
getting like the younger Generations
kept getting like like profited on and
like abused almost
when I heard this question I kind of
thought about like so like social
justice and like the issues that we're
experiencing right now like there can be
a change and I just really don't think
that people back in the day were seeing
that type of change everything was just
thrown kind of under the rug not really
spoken about I still love to dream like
oh I would love to achieve this one day
but even if I don't have that Financial
capability I still have hope I hope I
could get there one day and I still try
to remain positive everyone's goal at
the end of the day is just to be happy
in what they're doing and make a
difference in either your own or
someone's life and I think like just by
having this discussion like there's so
much hope for everyone in here to go on
and be successful in that no matter what
it is so I have a lot of Hope for the
future and I'm really excited even
though I'm nervous and I'm anxious about
a lot of it I'm really excited to see
like in my personal life like what that
means for me
um because I know I'm never gonna stop
until I'm happy with what I'm doing I
mean I feel really grateful for Our
Generation because a lot of us are very
open-minded to having these types of
conversations whether or not it relates
to us or exists in our nature but I feel
like people are so open to change now
and I feel like that's just great moving
forward and I feel like a lot of us gen
Z people have gone through such
traumatic and bad experiences that we're
gonna become amazing parents one day
like I think I remember like during
quarantine there was like a sign in New
York that said we had like this many
years left and before our world like
ends or something and my sister is an
iPad kid and I've seen like I've seen
how she is and it's like I I don't I
want to say I have hope for the future
but just based off what I'm seeing it
feels like there's no change kinda
[Music]
foreign